i
[Música]
y
ah
la plática que les graban a tratar de
dejar hoy transmitir un poquito de la
experiencia y de mi conocimiento y de mi
inspiración la he denominado
emprendimiento en un mundo cambiante
georgina me mientras estaba hace un
momento y me decía que cuál había sido
el reto más importante dentro de
liverpool para el comercio electrónico y
yo les decía que es un reto que no ha
terminado o sea no hubo un reto siempre
hay un reto en cualquiera de los
emprendimientos que hagamos
y para continuar un poquito con
digamos con un contexto antes de empezar
algo un poquito más divertido
discúlpenme si lo hago así pero de un
poquito la vieja escuela podría ser papá
de todos ustedes tengo 52 años en
escuelas un poquito oxígeno entonces
antes que nada yo quería decirles y esto
lo busqué en internet tampoco crean que
yo soy eminencia tengo equipo como se
come el emprendimiento y lo voy a leer
como definición de diccionario es el
inicio de una actividad que exige
esfuerzo o trabajo y que tiene cierto
si ustedes creen o la gente cree que
hacer un emprendimiento es fácil mejor
dedíquese atracos si creen que no lo van
a sufrir
tuvimos la oportunidad de escuchar una
preciosa pieza musical cuánto tiempo has
trabajado en ello cinco años no se pasen
los tengas pero cinco años tenías cuando
empezaste a tocar música ya ha sido una
constante hay un esfuerzo muy importante
casi no se ve el cuello pero el esfuerzo
es palabra clave dentro de una persona
que en el sitio puede emprender y hay
otras características relevantes de una
persona que es emprendedora
si no tienes estas características busca
desarrollarlas porque las vas a
necesitar en el campo y tú tienes que
tener una visión muy clara de dónde
quieres llegar es finalmente lo que nos
transmite el vídeo inicial llegar hasta
el final y para llegar hasta el final
necesitas tener una visión necesitará
una iniciativa una iniciativa que puede
ir desde
un café distinto al que ya conocemos en
la idea de hoy un transporte distinto al
que conocemos el día de hoy una manera
distinta de trabajar como sería un
espacio como núcleo tienes que tener
pasión si no tienes pasión en lo que vas
a hacer y no nada más para el
emprendimiento o sea para cualquier cosa
en la vida necesitas tener actuación una
relación una amistad en poner una casa
irte de viaje y un negocio también está
esta pasión sin pasión no hay
emprendimiento ambición y no una misión
entendida como que me quiera ser
millonario y es tiene una finalidad de
lucro no una ambición de hacer las cosas
por el bien de hacer las cosas mejores
podría ser que con nuestra iniciativa en
este emprendimiento muchas personas
mejoren su estilo de vida liderazgo es
básico para poder emprender una empresa
para poder emprender un negocio para
poder entender cualquier tipo de
iniciativa porque la gente sigue líderes
no sigue órdenes sigue líder
necesitamos inspirar a la gente para un
emprendimiento la resolución bueno pues
es determinante
qué necesitas tener
pantalones palabra para tomar decisiones
a veces difíciles camino ya que ser
determinante y tener resolución la
creatividad es básica en un mundo como
el que vivimos el día de hoy las redes
sociales es una locura la competencia no
es los amarillos no son los azules o no
son los rojos son los que están en china
son los que están en londres son los que
están online son los que ni siquiera
hemos visto toda la creatividad que
podamos imprimir en nuestros proyectos
de emprendimiento son muy muy
importantes la asertividad nos lleva a
un mundo en la comunicación en donde
tenemos ser claros con lo que porque
solos no vamos a poder emprender nada
quiero ser muy asertivos en lo que le
decimos a los demás y como subimos a los
demás salvando el aprendizaje también es
muy importante dado que en el camino y
como mencionaba el título de mi ponencia
es la constante es el cambio entonces en
el camino tenemos que ir aprendiendo y
todas las herramientas que hoy tenemos
en el mundo digital nos permiten tener
el control de la data muy fácil y por
último el optimismo como habrán visto en
el vídeo
y algunos alumnos nos identificamos de
un lado del otro
cuántas veces nos caemos en el camino
yo tengo más de 20 años trabajando en el
liverpool y hoy tengo el honor de iu del
área de relaciones públicas pero no ha
sido un camino si no entre de director
de los 200 públicas entré en una
coordinación que manejaba las ventas por
internet slam y llama al principio y me
he caído una y otra vez y 20 años fue
muy importante mantener el optimismo y
yo lo que digo siempre es y dios me
proveyó de un bote de pintura roses
porque cuando hay un problema sea con mi
bote de pintura rosa y no coincide con
el color del liverpool pero es esa parte
y siempre he pensado en el optimismo y
en el mundo color de rosa
vamos a repasar rápido algunos algunos
este emprendimiento célebres que hoy
seguramente rebota nuestra cabeza no
google snap chad thall box facebook über
todas estas personas que revolucionaron
la forma de hacer cosas que ya existían
es decir el emprendimiento no significa
que tenemos que inventar el hilo negro
el emprendimiento puede partir de una
idea que ya existe y se puede mejorar
samsung teniendo cocacola marriott de
ayer se sabe por ejemplo un barrio que
hoy es una cadena de hoteles empezó con
una idea completamente diferente ellos
tenían ganas de poner un barrio
solamente tienen por sus vaginas
entonces bueno aquí son algunos ejemplos
no estoy comiendo un poquito de mi
tiempo ya bien me están presionando aquí
con mi con mi reloj entonces después
cheque lo en internet esta información
también las aquello de internet y estar
un poquito de research para ustedes vean
cada uno de los casos porque de nuevo
suelen ser muy importantes para
inspirarnos
les voy a dar siete puntos de un
emprendimiento para el cambio yo creo
que si tenemos en la cabeza una idea de
emprendimiento que no tiene propósito no
lo hagamos necesitamos buscar que esa
idea tenga un propósito social un
propósito ecológico y un propósito de
sostenibilidad un propósito de ayuda
siempre la gente estamos buscando cómo
ayudar a los demás y si nosotros nos
queremos sumar a algo más grande que
nosotros que lo haga entonces dentro de
un proyecto de emprendimiento a mí me
parece que el propósito que tengamos
dentro de ello es muy importante si
queremos inventar esta nueva empresa
necesitamos tener siempre en la cabeza
que vamos a ir a trabajar y siempre
vamos a ir hacia adelante ayudando a
nuestro localismo nosotros en el
liverpool tenemos siempre el compromiso
de ser lo que conocemos como el buen
vecino a donde llegamos no nada más
llegamos con nuestra tienda de ponemos
nuestros productos abrimos las puertas y
vendemos siempre vemos hacia alrededor
que hay
qué podemos hacer por la comunidad cómo
nos ayudamos a tener una mejor vida
evidentemente con la oferta de productos
siempre están ahí pero hay un propósito
atrás de mejorar su calidad de vida en
todos los sentidos
y para tener un propósito en un
emprendimiento es muy importante revisar
los valores los valores que cada uno de
nosotros tengamos como empresarios como
emprendedores también van a ser muy
importantes plasmarlo en ese proyecto
la segunda cosa importante que les
quiero compartir en mi cabeza está el
valor como imprimo yo y como género un
valor para poder ganar la atención del
público hoy como les mencionaba hace un
momento vivimos en un mundo súper
competitivo cómo van a voltear a ver a
mí si mi proyecto de emprendimiento es
una app para hacer ejercicio y lo digo
porque mi sobrino está en ese camino
ahorita está emprendiendo lo goles de la
página para que entren a verlo pero yo
le digo iker cómo vas a hacer que tu
página de arte ejercicio sea distinta a
los demás cuál es tu valor agregado es
un emprendimiento muy delicado porque
hay 50 apps no sé quién de que haga
ejercicio tiene gusta ir al gimnasio o
hacer yoga lo que sea no aquí hay una
candidata gente todos son jóvenes
seguramente yo soy un fan de hacer
ejercicio
tengo miles de aplicaciones y ninguna me
engancha dónde está el valor piensen en
su proyecto de emprendimientos siempre
con un valor que los va a diferenciar de
los demás
es muy muy muy muy importante y
obviamente en la vida moderna y en la
vida actual la responsabilidad social la
parte humana la parte de ecología es muy
importante son elementos que ustedes en
su proyecto de emprendimiento tienen que
incluir y obviamente generando valor
bendito dios hoy tenemos una cantidad de
herramientas que casi no necesitamos de
nadie para hacer las cosas la
creatividad
es sumamente importante ya se mencionaba
en las características del emprendedor
muy al principio y hoy creo que llamar
la atención a través de
de creatividad es muy muy importante
como logramos hacer y si yo sigo con el
ejemplo de mi sobrino iker y su página
de hacer ejercicio cómo iba a lograr
hacer que la gente se suscriba a sus
clases tiene que meterle coco tiene que
meterle creatividad y ojo que actividad
no quiere decir este colores bonitos
gráficos increíbles fotografías de
verano la creatividad está en cómo
hacemos las cosas en los procesos que
ofrecemos quedamos qué horarios tenemos
abiertos en fin cada quien es un
proyecto de emprendimiento tiene que
pensar cómo ser creativo ustedes no lo
van a creer pero hasta un contador
público espero que no haya nadie control
público pero hasta un contador público
tiene que ser creativo no nada más ese
cargo y abono como hago para que las
finanzas en intereses sean
esta lámina hace alusión al título de mí
de mi implementación
estrategias de adaptación todo el tiempo
el mundo está cambiando en nuevos
jugadores salen los jugadores hay nuevas
herramientas hay nuevas
nuevos procesos hay más gente en fin es
un mundo cambiante y además de manera
acelerada también en la entrevista de
hace un ratito platicando con georgina
le decía que el proceso de la pandemia
ver pool lo que hizo fue acelerar los
teníamos construyendo presión durante 20
años un proceso del comercio electrónico
veníamos en un punto muy muy interesante
y donde estamos hoy pensamos estar en
cinco años
es lo que tuvimos que hacer cuando nos
agarrar la pandemia a todos hace
prácticamente un año con los dedos en la
puerta fue adaptarnos a esta palabra y
estas estrategias de actuación cuando
ustedes hagan un proyecto de
emprendimiento muy importante que lo
tengan presente para ver qué va a pasar
no nada más en dos meses o en tres meses
que voy a lanzar mi proyectos que va a
pasar en los siguientes seis meses que
ha pasado cuando cumple un año que va a
pasar cuando tenga días en liverpool es
una empresa que tiene 174 años es una
adaptación constante día con día
adaptarse es muy muy importante
la parte de las experiencias también es
muy relevante cuando ustedes piensan en
un proyecto de emprendimiento porque
porque usted lo van a ser mejor que
ellos son muy jóvenes la gente ya no
quiere comprar unos jeans ya no que
compraron usted ya no que compraron los
lentes de experiencias quiere vivir la
vida quiere tener el contenido para sus
redes sociales la verdad es que vivimos
pegados en su celular y estamos todo el
día viendo qué fotos tomamos qué vídeo
subimos porque yo empecé a subir mis de
ustedes que ya habíamos arrancado este
efe pero no porque creo que nos emociona
ser parte de una experiencia y vivir
experiencias entonces de nuevo cuando
ustedes piensen en su proyecto de
emprendimiento
experiencias va a tener la persona que
se acerca a su proyecto en el camino
y aquí sí márgenes un poquito más porque
hay un término que estamos importando
mucho que es el fin he tal dadas las
circunstancias veamos no soy no esté a
metro y medio uno está más cerquita pero
a metro y medio distancia con el bozal
este se llama cubrebocas
[Música]
entonces tenemos que ir combinando el
mundo físico con el mundo digital
entonces
hemos estado adaptando todas las
experiencias que teníamos al nivel culpa
de nuestros clientes en experiencias
digitales ustedes estos proyectos de
emprendimiento tienen que empezar en
cómo van a hacer esa certeza experiencia
que el cliente siente en el estómago su
producto su servicio no que lo salven o
que se lo tomen sino que lo siente en el
estómago y viva una experiencia
hablamos hace ratito de la data hoy
todas las herramientas que existe en el
mercado todos los proyectos de atrás de
crm nos permiten conocer a este cliente
que hoy vamos a tener nuestro proyecto
de emprendimiento hacer que sea el
cliente hacer que no sea su mercado
final con nuevos cuando entiendan cuáles
son sus necesidades
en mi época y en la época misa todos mis
abuelos pues por supuesto que había en
el mercado coca-cola no consumimos otra
cosa más que coca-cola no había opciones
hoy hay infinidad de marcas de refrescos
infinidad de marcas de celulares
infinidad de marcas de televisores antes
compramos lo que había yo todavía la
televisión de blanco y negro de acá me
tiene que levantar del sillón a
cambiarla
entonces no ven la tele usted en todo mi
celular
como como es nuestro producto y cómo es
nuestro mercado que quiere comprar y
consumidores conozcan muy bien muy
claramente cuál de su mercado final y
usen esa información para tomar diciendo
yo no sé si ustedes se sienten vigilados
yo sí
la semana pasada tuve oportunidad de
irme unos días a la playa con los amigos
todo sanitizados todos con prueba con
bien
vamos a protestar con vida
a partir de ese día al día de hoy me
llegan a ofertas de hoteles en estos
terrenos con boletos de bueno pero
difundido nos están vigilando entonces
ese tipo de cookies ese tipo de
herramienta este tipo de data usen las a
favor de ese emprendimiento y asustarse
de lo que están ustedes para ustedes
vigilen a su mercado vigilen a su
cliente entiendan no está parado
y luego
los xolos no van a poder el
emprendimiento es un proyecto
bien complejo
son proyectos que los intentamos hacer
solo no vamos a ir a ningún lado los
trabajen con sus equipos trabajen con
sus socios trabajen con la norma
anterior y la información con sus
clientes
y hagan de des emprendimiento una idea y
una estrategia integral nada más voy a
terminar con unas frases de inspiración
que me encontré por ahí y me gustaron me
gustaron muchísimo y las va a leer tal
cual nunca eres un joven para construir
tu imperio ni muy viejo para alcanzar
tus sueños tenido por tener practicar
con francisco de aquí del núcleo cuando
llegue y juste de ser está padrísimo
lugar pero con creencia y me siento un
poco fuera de lugar no puros chavos
desde
y platicando me di cuenta que hacía
alusión a esta primera fase que había
puesto nunca eres demasiado viejo para
empezar un sueño y nunca demasiado joven
para pensar en una gran gran imperio
entonces esta frase a mí me gustó
muchísimo
[Música]
no podemos elegir de dónde venimos
tenemos una circunstancia nacimos en un
lugar en un país en una ciudad con
ciertas características económicas
sociales físicas lo que sea pero si
podemos cambiarla donde género
y eso está en cada uno de nosotros y en
el emprendimiento que tengamos en la
cabeza la siesta para cumplir sueños no
para cumplir horarios en los que quienes
desean godín es yo sí pero no cumplo
horarios yo cumplo mis sueños cumplidos
es muy muy importante pensar en los
sueños y no perderlos nunca de visto en
el camino nos vamos a caer millones de
veces hay que levantarse pensando en esa
sueño inicial que teníamos todos van a
ver tus logros pero pocos durante
nuestra lucha van a llorar van ayudarles
a doble o todo se van a querer echar
para atrás van a querer tirar la toalla
pero al final todo mundo va plan estos
logros y ustedes se van a sentir muy
orgullosos
y la última idea es no soy diferente soy
único
gracias
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]